[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar y volvemos a hablar de esta
llamada viruela del mono repasamos
entonces las últimas declaraciones de la
organización mundial de la salud sobre
el brote de esta enfermedad buenos días
raúl pues efectivamente se han
actualizado la cifra de los casos
confirmados estamos hablando de 131
casos confirmados 106 sospechosos los
principales afectados son países como
españa portugal y reino unido en total
son 17 países que se han detectado esta
enfermedad donde normalmente no es
endémica en américa por ejemplo a pesar
de que el continente más afectado sigue
siendo europa américa canadá tiene cinco
casos eeuu 2 y se está estudiando uno en
argentina la organización mundial de la
salud también ha recordado que son focos
pequeños controlados que el riesgo para
la población es baja y también pues para
poner en contexto estas cifras república
democrática del congo uno de los lugares
donde si es endémica esta enfermedad ha
registrado unos 12.000 casos en lo que
va de año fuera de este país apenas se
llega a los 250 sumando los los
confirmados y los sospechosos ayer
también la organización mundial de la
salud aprovecho para hacer un llamado a
la calma escuchemos quiero reiterar que
es una situación contenible y que
podemos parar la transmisión entre
humanos
tenemos que usar los de la forma más
apropiada para los que están más en
riesgo de manera equitativa
bueno la pregunta del millón mar hay
razón para estarle alarmados por esta
viruela pues digamos que si no ya lo
hemos venido repitiendo también en este
espacio de salud por un lado obviamente
venimos arrastrando un cierto trauma de
la pandemia de kobe 19 y todo esto nos
recuerda mucho a eso también el nombre
tanto por la parte de viruela como por
la parte del mundo soy una especialmente
es alarmante pero es que la verdad que
estamos muy lejos de que esto se
convierta en una emergencia de salud
pública como la que fue la pandemia de
kobe 19 vamos a comparar un poco vamos a
explicar por qué en qué se diferencian y
en qué se parecen estos virus no ambos
tienen un origen zoonótico vienen de los
animales sin embargo el cubit era nuevo
este virus de la viruela del mono no es
nuevo en parte por la parte de la
transmisión el kobe 19 es mucho más
transmisible y además la viruela por
ejemplo sólo se contagia cuando una
persona es sintomática cosa que hace
mucho más fácil cortar la cadena de
transmisión y también pues necesita un
contacto mucho más estrecho que el del
cob y 19 estos brotes iniciales también
en el caso del cobach sucedieron en
muchos lugares y era muy difícil
rastrear esa cadena de contagios por lo
tanto cuando hubo empezó a ver una
respuesta ya era mucho más tarde había
mucha transmisión comunitaria en
términos también de respuesta y de
contención la viruela del mono es una
enfermedad que ya ha sido contenida en
el pasado que es conocida tiene vacunas
tiene tratamientos disponibles en el
caso de condición haber recordemos que
en 2020 estábamos totalmente en ceros
así es marc pasamos a otro tema vamos a
hablar de las olas de calor y como nos
pueden afectar la salud ahora y en los
próximos años exacto vemos que ya está
sucediendo en muchos lugares por ejemplo
en india en españa en francia en los
últimos días no es una novedad que el
cambio climático va a ser una de las
mayores crisis que vamos a enfrentar en
el futuro pero vamos a hablar
específicamente de los efectos de estas
olas de calor hay algunos efectos de
directos como estos golpes de calor que
es cuando el cuerpo no puede regular su
propia temperatura se puede llegar
llegar a dañar los órganos de manera
irreversible y provoca incluso en los
peores casos la muerte también se
empeoran enfermedades que ya existen
enfermedades cardiovasculares por
ejemplo también enfermedades como la
diabetes enfermedades de riñón y por
último muy importante también recordar
esos efectos indirectos que pueden ser
la saturación de los sistemas de salud
sobre todo la ralentización de las
respuestas de urgencias por ejemplo de
las ambulancias y algo en lo que muchas
veces no pensamos también es que muchos
medicamentos necesitan conservarse a
ciertas temperaturas de refrigeración
eso pues también puede suponer un
problema cuando estamos en una situación
de calor extremo estas olas de calor mar
pueden afectar a todo el mundo por igual
pues digamos que tienen un mayor efecto
en la población vulnerable como muchas
otras condiciones climáticas la gente
mayor la infancia también personas con
discapacidades personas en condición de
embarazo pero es que también hay una
cuestión social hay una cuestión de
clase en este aspecto y es que por
ejemplo afecta más a todos esos
trabajadores por ejemplo de la
construcción que tienen que trabajar en
exterior y en condiciones de calor
extremo también esas personas que no se
pueden permitir dejar de trabajar en el
verano por ejemplo en los lugares donde
hay estaciones no que suelen ser además
trabajos menos calificados y esas
personas que no tienen tampoco pues
buenas condiciones de vivienda empezando
por las personas sin techo pero también
la gente que no tiene aire acondicionado
que no tiene buenos aislantes en casa
además todas estas diferentes sociales
también se reflejan en el mapa global
aquí revisamos este mapa que hizo la
universidad de hawai en un estudio y
representa los días de calor extremo que
se prevé que habrá en los años entre el
2000 90 y el 2100 en unas 78 décadas si
nada cambia y si no se frena el cambio
climático vemos que el sur global como
siempre por ejemplo pues áfrica américa
latina' el sureste asiático también son
las zonas que van a recibir pues la peor
parte de estas olas de calor con los
consecuentes efectos sobre la salud que
estábamos comentando nosotros aquí en
colombia por ejemplo estaríamos
rostizados por supuesto efectivamente
también en algunas zonas del puente
bueno mar muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información esperemos que
todo sea real y que pues los gobiernos y
también todos nosotros pongamos de
nuestra parte para así salvar nuestro
planeta y no llegamos a esos extremos
marcha queremos esperemos muchísimas
gracias como siempre mañana nos vemos
con más salud pues vamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo